[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact for those of you who love
new tech gadgets there's one in eastern
Tennessee now that should really impress
you sumit a new supercomputer unveiled
at Oak Ridge National Lab is now
believed to be the most powerful
calculating machine on the planet built
by IBM it was designed to enhance the
artificial intelligence features in your
smartphone China's held the official
title for the fastest computers since
2013 but now it's estimated that the
summit is 60 percent faster than China's
ty who light supercomputer the new sumit
supercomputer occupies floor space
equivalent to two tennis courts and it
requires 4,000 gallons of water a minute
to circulate around and cool it's 37,000
processors Oak Ridge says its new baby
can deliver a peak performance of 200
quadrillion calculations per second
that's 200 followed by 15 zeros or 200
Petra flops for those of you who speak
computer EES that's about a million
times faster than the typical laptop
during early testing researchers at Oak
Ridge use summit to perform more than
quintillion calculations per second in a
project analyzing human genome sequences
they claim that's the first time a
scientific calculation has reached that
computational scale did you know the
Bible prophecy tells us that one of the
signs in the last days is going to be an
the increase in knowledge
stay tuned friends we're going to learn
more on this edition of Bible answers
live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 it's because
our volunteers who are Manning the
phones they're just gonna let it ring
for a minute why they put other callers
on hold but we'd love to hear from you
want to welcome those who may be
watching as we're who are viewing on our
Facebook account I am pastor Doug
Batchelor pastor Ross is out of town
this evening and we're gonna begin this
program with a word of Prayer loving
Lord again we always thank you for the
opportunity to gather as a radio family
and to study your word we pray that
you'll just take charge of every aspect
of this program that in the questions
that are asked and especially the answer
is given that the truth will be learned
and Jesus will be glorified we pray in
his name amen you know friends um one of
the interesting prophecies you read in
the end of the Book of Daniel you find
it in Daniel chapter 12 verse 4 it says
but you Daniel shut up the words and
seal the book until the time of the end
many will run to and fro and knowledge
will increase well just in my short
lifetime knowledge has increased more
than in all the known history of man I
mean you think about it and people were
riding horses for 6,000 years until the
invention of the car by Henry Ford and
now you know of course people are
traveling supersonic speeds and
the knowledge that transmits via the
internet is just mind-boggling and
Daniel said one of the signs the end is
going to be knowledge will increase and
even as I speak right now this message
is being bounced from earth 23,000 miles
up in space ricochets off a satellite up
there comes down too many people who are
listening now on satellite radio driving
in your car your truck across the
country
matter of fact you might want to give us
a call if you have a Bible question but
the Bible foretells that this is going
to be a sign we're living in the last
days my grandfather
does one generation ago they rode horses
in New York City where he was born and
they were born at home back then a radio
was a new invention there was no TV
there were no airplanes and and cars
were a novelty meet just in one lifetime
look at how the world has changed Jesus
said if he doesn't come soon that
problems in the last days are gonna be
so serious that no flesh would survive
now we have a special offer we'd like to
make available if you have an interest
in Bible prophecy this one doesn't deal
specifically with the prophecy about
knowledge it's the us a in Bible
prophecy the United States in Bible
prophecy if you would like a free copy
of that two ways to get it one call the
number you're the place where you can do
this just call free phone call 808 three
five six seven four seven seven that's
800 eight three five six seven four
seven ask for the study guide the USA
and Bible prophecy tell them you're
listening to Bible answers live if you
want to get it via computer then all you
need to do is go to amazing facts dot
o-r-g and you go to our Bible study
guide lesson there you can download a
PDF of this and read all that
fascinating information there there's
also pictures I like the pictures you
can look at two that help illustrate the
points in the prophecy well with that
lengthy introduction we're gonna get to
the phones and take our first caller
talking to rose calling from New York
and Huntington Station rose you're on
the air with Bible answers live thank
you pastor Doug thank you for your
patience
this question has been bothering me for
a long time I love God so much but I
have to admit that I get a little upset
with him as as well if that's okay the
devil turn one set of one set of the
Angels against him and he kicked him out
of heaven and sent him down here to
bother us so it's because of that we are
dealing with so much pain and suffering
but my question is why would God send
him down here knowing what he would what
trouble he was cause for us well God did
not say I think I want to just send the
devil devil to earth to harass the
humans what happened is there was no
place on the world that the devil could
tempt or speak to Adam and Eve except
the knowledge of the tree of good and
evil the devil claimed he could do a
better job governing the universe than
God God could have just destroyed him
but then the other creatures would
listen to God out of fear instead of
love so the Lord allowed the devil to
share his point of view to communicate
with unfallen worlds like ours in a
limited way but when Adam Eve chose to
listen to the word of the devil when God
said do not eat the tree the devil said
eat it
and when they chose to listen to the
devil in the set of God they basically
surrendered the Dominion of the world
God gave Adam and Eve dominion of the
planet to the enemy so Satan was
restricted to this planet so really the
first humans sort of invited the devil
in the door when they chose to listen to
the Word of God instead of the Word of
Satan Romans chapter six said whoever
you obey that's whose servant you are
and when they chose to obey the devil
even Jesus said the Prince of this world
he talked about the devil he said the
prince of this world comes and he has
nothing in me the devil kind of claimed
dominion of his planet Jesus came to
ransom the planet with his own life and
blood he doesn't want anybody to perish
he doesn't want anyone to suffer that's
why God's sent his son so there's a big
cosmic battle going on between good and
evil God did not just decide to dream up
a devil one day
beautiful perfect angel chose to rebel
because he had freedom and God had to
allow all of this to play out so it'll
never happen again that's a long
explanation but can I give you a study
guide that explains that it for free
Rose would that be all right yeah it's
called did God create a devil that will
answer your questions on this subject
did God create a devil and if you call
them they will be happy to send that to
you and we thank you for your patience
in your call journey back through time
to the center of the universe discover
how a perfect angel transformed into
Satan the arch villain the birth of evil
a rebellion in heaven immunity that
moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil
discover God's amazing plan to save his
children this is a story that involves
every life on Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
[Music]
four life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm talking next to
Roger in Arvada Colorado and Roger if
you've got your radio on you're gonna
want to turn it off or you're gonna get
a delay and it'll be confusing Roger are
you there yes I am okay and your
question tonight I've been told many
times by people that revelation only is
important in the first century it has
nothing to do with our time but myself
knowing that I've been reading
revelation a few times shows me
different and somebody says the lake of
fire you are going to be able to see
when you're living with God well you got
several questions there first question
how relevant is revelation and is it all
mostly fulfilled I'd say that a lot of
Revelation is not fulfilled there are
there one group of people when they look
at revelation they're called preterists
that word preterist means pre they think
that most of Revelation was fulfilled in
the first hundred years after Jesus they
think Nero was the Antichrist and all
those prophecies are just talking about
the battle between the Christians Jews
in Rome then you've got people who are
called historic that's what I am the
most of the Protestant reformers were
his stores like Martin Luther John
Wesley Spurgeon they're they're all his
stories and we believe that panorama cuz
it covers up our revelation covers a
panorama of Christian history from the
first coming to the second coming so a
lot of it's still happening then you've
got futurists that would be like Hal
Lindsey in' and
Tim LaHaye and the people the Left
Behind group they believe that from
Revelation 4 everything's in the future
they're called futurists so when you
look at Revelation
you can see that the vision of the seven
churches covers a panorama of church
history from the first coming to the
second coming then there's a separate
vision called the seven seals it covers
the political history from the first
coming to the second coming then you've
got one called the seven trumpets it
covers a military history of the world
in the church from the first coming to
the second coming and so and you can
point out all these and see them
dramatically fulfilled and now your
second question was about the lake of
fire there will be a time when the
righteous will be in the city and God
will rain fire down out of heaven on the
wicked we won't watch that through
eternity but there'll be a period of
judgment at the end of the 1,000 years
you read about that in Revelation 20 and
that's probably what you're referring to
am i right Roger yes yes it is so
there's a brief period but don't forget
you're not going to hear that all the
time because God said he'll wipe away
all tears from their eyes there'll be no
more pain no more suffering the former
things will not come into mind
Aurel were they be remembered and it
says the righteous will go forth from
the New Jerusalem they will build houses
and inhabit them they'll plant vineyards
and eat the fruit of them God creates a
new heaven and a new earth I'm quoting
the Bible and all these statements and
so we're not going to be staring at
people burning through eternity that
would be pretty morbid I do have a
lesson on that I will send you for free
if you'd like it yeah all right all
you've got to do is call the number it's
one eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven ask for the study guide
on a thousand years of peace
they'll send that to you for free
anybody out there if you want to
understand this subject they'll do that
for you I want to remind our friends if
you've got the internet or you can log
onto Facebook we are broadcasting the
video live such as it is you know people
think they're going to tune in to the
Bible answer program and I'll be sitting
here in a tuxedo or something but it's
all pretty casual but you can at least
get the visual of what's happening here
all right all systems go going to talk
next to Eleazar in Longmont Colorado
Eleazar you're on the air with Bible
answers life
oh yeah good thank you for calling and
your question that question of what get
real close to your phone you sound like
you're in Colorado my question was I had
a family member that asked me so if I
was sealed by the Holy Spirit when I got
baptized when I asked that to Jesus why
do I want to be filled again like it's
red and red like all right well there
that's a good question if you receive
the Holy Spirit at baptism then why do
you need to receive the seal of God as
it's mentioned in Revelation well there
are two different dimensions of filling
with the spirit and sealing with the
spirit an example the Apostles had the
Holy Spirit when they went out teaching
for Jesus while Jesus was still alive
Christ would never send them out to
teach without a measure of the Spirit
but they received a special filling of
the Holy Spirit at Pentecost on Acts
chapter 2 they received a filling again
it's like the Holy Spirit can come in
waves you read in Acts chapter 4 they
prayed and they were again filled with
the Holy Spirit you look at the life of
Samson and several times he was filled
with the spirit when there was a special
need and he'd go fight a Philistine or a
lion or whatever it was the filling of
the Spirit and the sealing of the Spirit
they can happen in different degrees you
are sealed with the Holy Spirit you can
read about if you've got your Bible
there and you look in Ephesians chapter
2 you read in verse 13 you were sealed
with the Holy Spirit of promise there's
a promise that God seals to us when
we're married to him through the Holy
Spirit and you can read in Ephesians
4:30 do not grieve the Holy Spirit of
God by whom you were sealed for the day
of redemption so the Holy Spirit is an
internal seal and you know God is
leading and guiding and convicting when
you follow him but then there's a seal
that is in the law of God you read in
Isaiah chapter 8 verse 16 bind the
testimony seal the law among my
disciples
and so within the law of God you find
the name of God and the seal of God and
many people believe that that's found in
the fourth commandment it's gonna be a
special test in the last days hopefully
that answers your question now Eliezer
I've got a free lesson I'll be happy to
send you on that subject if you'd like
it and I think you're gonna find it
you'd find it very encouraging are you
interested in that yeah yeah yeah
absolutely I think that you'll be
blessed I want to send you a mess in
there I want to send ya I think I'm
gonna send you the lesson called the
mark of the beast because the mark of
the beast is the opposite of the seal of
God so if you call the number 808 three
five six seven four seven that's 808
three five six seven four seven telling
you're listening to Bible answers live
and you'd like the free lesson on the
mark of the beast they'll send it to you
and thank you for your call talking next
with Stacey in Atlanta Georgia hi Stacey
it's live you're real on the air turn
your radio down okay
okay hello hi and your question tonight
my question is Isaiah this pastor does
this is him in the flesh well on the
radio anyway I was just watching you so
I guess there must be a little bit of a
delay here Isaiah 11 verses 6 through 9
is that the millennial period let me
read this for our friends that are
driving down the road the wolf will also
do well with the lamb and the leopard
will lie down with a young goat and of
course he's talking about the new heaven
new earth the calf and the young lion
and the fatling together and a little
child will lead them the cow and the
bear shall graze their young ones shall
lie down together so I come in a
peaceful world none of the animals kill
each other anymore
the lion will eat straw like the Ox a
nursing child will play by the Cobras
hole the weaned child shall put his hand
on the Vipers den they will not hurt or
destroy in all the holy mountain I think
this is talking more about after the
Millennium when God creates the new
heaven and the new earth now who's to
say when you get into the Garden of Eden
during the Millennium you the garden
will be in the
because The Tree of Life is in the city
God may have some beasts and creatures
there but I think Isaiah here's looking
at the long picture of what life will be
like in the new world after everything
is restored to its identity okay that's
not the millennium so there's going to
be reproduction and well there'll be no
there'll be no children you know Jesus
said we do not marry nor are we given in
marriage there you know when God first
makes or recreates the animals everyone
wants to know will my pet be in heaven
but so he might surprise some people
there but some of the animals may
procreate until they fill the earth but
what God told Adam and Eve he said be
fruitful multiply and fill the earth in
other words populated but he didn't want
them to overpopulate it now in the
resurrection God is going to have
millions of not billions of people so
he's not gonna want us to forever be
marrying and reproducing the pleasures
in heaven are gonna be far beyond
anything we can think of here on earth
so there's really no comparison but we
won't need to forever procreate that's
what I think Jesus is saying does that
make sense yes I was just wondering
because if that's not in the millennial
period and I they were talking about
children playing with yeah well there
are children in the resurrection you
might be thinking well how can those
children be a thousand years old and
still be children you know there's a
verse in Isaiah 65 it's as a child won't
even cease to be a child until it's a
hundred the children will grow up very
slowly in the new earth I think we're
gonna enjoy everything a lot a lot
longer okay I mean speaking of heaven it
says and children will play in the
streets of the New Jerusalem that's
another passage and they'll be singing
so yeah it's gonna be beautiful hey
thank you and you know if you'd like
Stacey we do have a lesson that talks
about heaven and it's called God's City
and space and you can get that free call
883 five six seven four seven or go to
amazing facts dot o-r-g and you can just
download that lesson about god's amazing
city in space
appreciate your call oh let me see here
gonna talk to Emma calling from Dallas
Texas Emma you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi hi thank you for calling
and your question my question is it's
eating techniques a abomination to God
even if we know that we're eating it
well I I don't make up the Bible I'll
just tell you that God said that you
should not eat Pig you know just if you
just back up a little bit and think
about it when God first made the animals
did he intend for Adam and Eve to
butcher and eat them you still there
Emma did we lose you am i you there yes
okay did did God intend for Adam and Eve
to butcher and eat animals no no not in
Paradise nothing died so first of all he
never intended for us to kill and need
any animals but then after sin he said
all right you can eat the clean animals
because during the flood all the
vegetation was destroyed and God
specified some animals would be clean
for sacrificing clean for food and those
things have to have a cloven hoof and
they've got to chew the cud and he said
like a deer a goat you know lamb those
were clean animals then things some
animals are scavengers they're never to
be eaten God says he'll get sick for an
abomination and that would be you don't
need a skunk you don't need a budget
Buzzard and you don't eat cockroaches
and you don't eat pigs pigs are
scavengers they are filthy animals the
Jewish world knows that they will not
eat pigs the Muslim world even knows
that they will not eat pigs and
Christians should not eat them but some
pastors say it doesn't matter what you
eat as long as you pray over it which i
think is i think that's irresponsible no
parent will tell their child that people
shouldn't be eating pigs they're unclean
can I give you a Bible study on that or
for free it's got new and Old Testament
Scriptures on the subject you still
there Emma yes I am
you okay all right let me tell you if
you call and you ask for God's free
health plan here's the number 808 three
five six seven four seven ask for God's
free health plan they will send that to
you for anyone listening you can also
read that if you just type in God's free
health plan amazing facts I found that
Google is so efficient these days it'll
just pop up and you can look at it right
there just type in God's free health
plan it'll tell you about what the Bible
says about health not just the the meat
and unclean thing it tells you
principles to have a longer stronger
abundant life from the Bible and I've
tried to follow those for 40 years and
I'm in pretty good shape for a
grandfather with eight grandkids so
gonna talk next to Nancy we'll get
another call in before our break Nancy
in Orlando Florida you're gonna be here
in a delay until you turn your radio
down I did okay and your question
tonight
a question is from the Book of Daniel
when he had the dream about the tree and
the birds yeah you were cutting out a
little bit so he the the dream about the
tree and the tree is cut down and all
the creatures are in the shade
yeah never could never can either
basically was like an animal and he had
you know his nails grew and he had no
lost contact with people right when then
when that happened with him basically in
the garden area he wasn't like out in
the wild of of Babylon wouldn t have
been basically kind of watched over by
people of the palace yeah I I don't
think that Nebuchadnezzar was sent out
when he lost his mind for seven years I
think his advisers and wise men and the
the palace as far as poeple possible
tried to keep that a secret there were
beautiful Hanging Gardens of Babylon
there were fields and the King had royal
he had royal territories and farmlands
and the Nebuchadnezzar was probably out
there somewhere when his mind came back
he said
weiter right away restored him to his
office you know there that's happened in
history before there's the King of
England actually lost his mind thing was
King George he lost his mind for several
years and the the cabinet kind of kept
it secret so it's not the first time
that's happened you know it says his
fingernails grew and they were unkempt
and his hair was long and matted like
birds feathers and he just was out of
his mind
because he had been so proud of his
wisdom but he was I presume and your ear
is reassuring me that he would have been
kept in the power more or less yeah I
think somebody had him in some area or
some grounds does he eat grass like the
oxen somebody had him in some protected
area it may have been you know a royal
pasture forest or something not a lot of
forest around babbling so I want to be
careful not to say that it's it's a lot
of planes and farmland in there yeah the
grass would have been if they said he
ate girl yep and and he was out of his
mind during that time but yeah that's a
it's a fascinating vision that you read
about in Daniel 4 and I think there's a
lot to that it tells us about pride and
what happens if we're if we're proud we
can lose our reason and suffer for that
as well let me see if we you know I'm
looking and I don't think we're gonna
have time to do another question justice
before the break well maybe we'll get
started on one hi Linda you're on the
air with Bible answers live can you go
ahead and stage your question and maybe
we'll get to the bigger answer after our
break okay okay thank you
and what is your question um yet
regarding 1417 and then I want to jump
down to 21 Colossians chapter 2 verse 14
to 17 all right and then jumping to 21
so I tell you what I'm gonna go there
now but we're probably not gonna have
time to dig into it until we get back
from the break so if you stand by your
verses and your question is going to be
the first one we're going to address
after the break don't go anywhere Linda
friends we are gonna take some time for
station identification and be right back
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named Rahm was violent they were
ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
see his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com if you enjoy
hearing solid biblical answers on Bible
answers live you can have those same
insights at your fingertips through the
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols chart and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 Strava lling
on a speaking appointment this week and
I'm going to go back to Linda who had a
question about Colossians 2 and I'm
gonna read verse 14 to 17 is that right
Linda yeah okay let me let me read that
for our friends that are driving down
the road having wiped out the
handwriting of requirements that was
against us which was contrary to us and
he's taken it out of the way having
nailed it to the cross having disarmed
principalities and powers he made a
public spectacle of them triumphing over
them in it so let no one judge you in
food or a drink or regarding a festival
or a new moon or Sabbath's which are
shadow of things to come but the
substance is of Christ all right now
your question on that well I totally
believe in the commandments which
includes fourth because I do believe it
was first instituted
Garden of Eden Ryan Genesis and and I
understand I mean that points out
clearly in verse 14 blotting out the
handwriting of Ordinances and nailing it
to the clocks and then it coats down to
it or in which any holyday or of the new
moon or sabbath days
are you wondering does this mean was the
Sabbath day blotted out I'm sorry
Sabbath day blotted out I'm not quite
understanding it are you wondering what
this first means well I want to ask more
about specifically about 16 let no man
therefore judge you and meet her and
dreams so you're wondering what that
means yeah in the time when this was
written the the Jewish believers in
Christ were very sensitive about whether
or not they could eat the food that was
bought in the pagan Roman market places
around the Roman Empire because before
an animal was butchered it was offered
to pagan gods like Jupiter Apollo's her
Dian are one of the other gods and they
would do that with both the wine and
with the meat and they said oh man we
shouldn't be eating this and and if the
Gentiles ate it the Jews would judge
them and say you shouldn't eat that that
was offered to a pagan god it would be
like it would be like today I think many
of us have been to Chinese restaurants
or a Thai restaurant you'll see a little
statue of Buddha sometimes when you go
in and if your Christian friends say you
can't eat at that restaurant there's a
Buddha in there you're worshipping
Buddha well
most Christians would say you know I'm
not worshipping Buddha they do I mean
just because it's in the restaurant it
doesn't mean I'm worshipping Buddha well
that they were having the same problem
back then in the Roman Empire Paul
saying don't let them judge you you know
if it bothers her conscience don't take
them out to eat at that restaurant but
don't let people judge you he wasn't
saying that you could eat anything you
want and you don't have to worry about
it anymore he was basically saying don't
let people judge you that if you buy
food in the marketplace that it's been
offered to a pagan god you can't eat it
any more but he's talking about clean
food hopefully that helps a little you
would also I think enjoy that study
guide we offered earlier talking about
gods free health plan and to get that
call 808 three five six seven four seven
all right hey Thank You Linda we need to
move on and we're gonna talk next to
Peter calling from New Jersey Peter
you're on the air hello pastor I had a
question about Bible translations first
two questions actually one is um what do
you think of Young's literal translation
of the Bible and then the second one
will be why don't we have a perfect
translation in our language a lot of
times you'll hear the Bible teachers say
well that works have been translated a
little better and and it's a well if you
keep hearing it enough you might say
well how would we ever know which is the
word if one word could be translated in
four or five different words how are we
going to be absolutely positive we have
to be a literal word of God yeah that's
a good question well first of all the
the essence of what we read in the Bible
is very accurately translated if right
now on my computer I've got a program
that anybody can download it's free at
least the basic versions are free it's
called a sword and I sure appreciate
them putting it out there for everybody
and I can click between young literal
translation New King James English
standard American Standard and you read
them and as you go from verse to verse
you say it's really saying the same
thing verse after verse afterwards
little words might be different that
have a little different nuance but the
overall meaning is the same you can read
John 3:16 in virtually any translation
and you're gonna get the same message
there are 10 different ways of a person
saying a sentence that can mean the same
thing there's different words you can
choose you know what I mean the meaning
that is given in the Bible in these you
know there's better is there some
translations I'll admit are better than
others but the overall meaning people
can find the gospel and they can find
God's will for their lives in
translations now there are more versions
of the Bible in English than any other
language you go to a lot of languages
there's just one translation maybe two
English we've probably got you know 50
different translate
or more I've got a book I can send you
on that for free Peter you still there
yes I had one more question if you don't
well and then I'll tell you about the
book ok so then is what Bible do you use
and what what what Bible would you say
or is there any Bible that we could say
is 100% accurately translated from the
original manuscripts of Greek and Hebrew
all the Hebrew is translated from
virtually the same you know we got a
Greek version called the Septuagint and
then the others you know you have the
some of the original but the Hebrew
Bible dates back before Jesus and nobody
really contests that the New Testament
which came to us in Greek I believe the
most accurate are the ones that came
from the manuscripts called the Textus
Receptus or the received texts that
would be the King James Version the New
King James Version which is what I
typically preach from the New King James
Version slight differences from the King
James just that you don't use some of
the old archaic English that people you
know we don't say we're for that one to
show you your servant you know we you
say it yes you get rid of these in the
vowels and you talk normally so the New
King James is basically the same it's
just kind of modernized some of the
terminology the other one I like is the
American Standard Version right now I'm
reading through the English standard
version it's not bad to read through
another translation sometimes like I
said you'll pick up little nuances that
you missed the first time through let me
send you a book that I wrote on the
Bible and it's called the ultimate
resource and it answers some of these
questions would that be okay yes pastor
none of those Bibles none of the verses
changed the context in any way of the
translations there probably are a few
places where you're going to see a
change in meaning but it's very few when
you consider the millions of words in
the Bible but overall the the gist is
the same now the translations I just
gave you those the ones I think are good
if you're working with a paraphrase
there that's a little different that's
like you know the the good news Bible
that's where someone kind of takes it
and puts it in their own words and why
there's some wild differences there
like you get to the mark of the beast'
they say it's a tattoo in the right hand
to the forehead well the original
language doesn't call it a tattoo issue
that's a pretty big Liberty he's taking
there so anyway I hope that helps a
little let me give you that number if
you want for the free offer you can call
808 three five six seven four seven the
book is called the ultimate resource on
the Bible if you enjoy hearing solid
biblical answers on Bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols chart and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy to seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
538 seventy two seventy five find out
what the critics are raving about top
scholars and theologians from around the
country come together to reveal the
hidden history of the book of Revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects this 95 minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
Revelation like never before revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today visit iTunes or AF bookstore calm
and with that we're gonna go and talk to
who do we got going in here Stacy is it
Compton California Stacy
Oh hi ru you call him Bible answers live
with a question yeah you're on the
question is on Ezekiel 1116 what it says
that the kids want to have I mean when
he gave earrings to the other people and
everything explained to me
yeah well it's talking about when God
called his people out of Egypt and he's
describing he says I made you like my
bride you can read in Ezekiel 16 10 I
think it's a verse you're talking about
so I clothed thee also with broidered
work and with badger skin course those
are things that were in the temple i
girded you about with fine linen and i
covered you with silk i decked you with
ornaments I put bracelets on your hands
chains on your neck and I put a jewel in
your forehead and earrings in your ears
and a beautiful crown on your head now
these are things that a bride might wear
on her wedding day cuz the money the
dowry and the gifts they gave the bride
were usually jewels that she kept with
her through her life and it was
considered great value that she could
put towards her home and other things
it's it's talking about God said I
married you when the children of Israel
came out of Egypt they spoiled the
Egyptians and the Egyptians gave them
articles of gold and silver and precious
cloth and jewels and they brought that
with them into the wilderness and they
made a beautiful tabernacle and so God
here through Ezekiel is telling me in
this poetic language you were my bride
and I married you and I gave you all
this wealth when you came out of Egypt
and you've now played the harlot with
these other gods from other nations so
that's really what he's talking about
I hope that helps a little bit to our
caller from Compton and talking now to
Antoniou Antonio New York New York
you're on the air yes hi there I'm here
you can put your you can turn your radio
down and your question okay let me turn
my radio down now can you hear me now I
can your question I'm gonna see if I can
put it together to you this is about
David when
they King David when God promised that
out of him would always who King would
always be sitting on his throne yes and
of course the Lord Jesus Christ was
promised he was going to come out of the
tribe of Judah which is the traveler
David right now what I'm trying I'm
trying to put together is that David
when he was sick
getting ready to die when he was dying
it was very sick he was very cold and I
they had they look for a virgin and they
got a young girl by the name of Abishag
to cuddle him to keep him warm right and
so in other words he slept with a virgin
right it yeah it it was just purely
medicinal and then and then then the
Lord Jesus Christ was born out of the
virgin which Virgin Mary and also Joseph
came out of the tribes tribe of Judah
both of them
they wore from the blood of David you
know that's an interesting analogy King
David is a type of Christ he slept with
a virgin and then the next king was
Solomon who's the son of David and he
was a type of Christ in which he also
promises in the book of chronic to
Solomon which is very interesting what
you reading there also but what I was
what I was trying to you know this
question I wanted to ask you about three
years ago and I couldn't do it because
somebody that answers the phone she
could understand what I was talking
about and I was not able to answer but I
did this has been in my mind for years
and years if there's any connection with
with David been a king sleeping with a
virgin before he died and then the Lord
Jesus Christ came out of David you know
as far as coming from the tribe of Judah
but for me it's not working Lennox right
am I correct
yeah it's true that David came that
Jesus came from the line of David of
course he had no children with Abhishek
so Jesus didn't come through Abhishek
tells us that Jesus came through
Bathsheba and Solomon and on down to
David you can read the DNA genealogy
find it two places matthew traces the
genie
ecology of Jesus through his father
Joseph Luke chapter 3 traces the
genealogy of Jesus through Joseph's
father-in-law Mary's father that's where
there's a slight difference yep and that
all goes back to David either river that
you take a thank you on Tony on thank
you for your patience with that we're
gonna talk to Lisa calling from Georgia
Lisa you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi this is Lee Sang
Waycross
thank you for calling your question yeah
my question is in Isaiah talks about how
the land malaya the lion well you know
there's nothing in the Bible that says
animals will be resurrected but there's
nothing in the Bible that says that God
can't resurrect them so I think once we
start speculating and a lot of people
especially with their pets they want to
know you know I just had this animal
that I loved and it was such a good pant
and I'm gonna miss it so much and can't
God resurrect it and you know I've got a
friend Steve Wolford he wrote a book
called will my pet be in heaven and I
think he makes an argument that God can
surprise us and do that but I can't
point you to a scripture where it says
that God is going to resurrect the
animals from this life and give them new
bodies in the world to come yeah I've
got to be careful not to go where the
Bible doesn't go there will definitely
be animals in heaven it mentions bears
lions talks about snakes it talks about
wolves talks about lambs talks about
cows all being in heaven
yeah God's gonna repopulate the world
with many yeah and you know we look at
the fossil record today and we can see a
lot of animals have become extinct just
imagine the variety that God will have
in the new earth it'll it'll be as you
ologists dream so you still there ELISA
well yes and so true and I always as
always love listen to the Word of God
god bless you you have a good evening
all right hey thank you so much for your
question in your call one's a know God's
plan for our world and solutions for
your life's challenges
we redesigned amazing facts 27 Bible
study guides provide encouraging Bible
based answers to questions on healthier
relationships when Jesus will return and
much more prefer to watch while you read
our brand new prophecy encounters DVD
series makes the perfect companion set
order your study guides and DVDs today
by visiting AAF bookstore com or by
calling 858 seven two seven five you're
listening to Bible answers live this
broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific Time call us at
one eight hundred seven is easy cure' on
the air hey pastor bachelor it's always
a privilege also I want to study before
my question is I'm enjoying reading your
daily devotional world of wonder oh
pretty I highly recommend it to anybody
but my question is I saw one of your
sermons where you said that Daniel was a
eunuch I've never heard any other
pastors say that before yeah well I'm
sure I'm not the only pastor that said
it it's really clear if you look in
Daniel chapter one it tells us that
Daniel and his three friends after being
carried off to Babylon to train in the
court of Nebuchadnezzar Nebuchadnezzar
commits them into the hands of ashvin as
the master of the eunuchs that's Daniel
chapter 1 verse 3 a eunuchs were men who
had been castrated and if you were gonna
work in the king's palace and be
anywhere near his harem his wise men
many of them went through that process
and Jesus talks about they're some
people who are made eunuchs by others
there are some people who make
themselves eunuchs for the kingdom of
heaven's sake some men choose to be
celibate and some women she used to be
celibate and then one other thing is
you'll you'll read a prophecy that God
gives in Isaiah
I think it's chapter 39
or Isaiah says - hey Hezekiah your
children are gonna be taking captives
some of your offspring and they're going
to be eunuchs in the palace of Babylon
and Daniel you never read about Daniel
Hananiah Mishael Azariah never got
married never had family no prosperities
ever mentioned Daniel was a eunuch it's
I think pretty clear from the context
that mentions eunuch several times in
the first chapter okay well thank you
for letting me call and share thank you
again brother camping oh he gets
actually brother bachelor but I have
priests need to call thank you very much
amazing fax offer some of the best
Christian resources for all ages we have
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the Lord
enjoy incredible facts and inspiring
spiritual essence in a world of wonders
daily devotional with facts from nature
science history technology and more it's
great for the whole family get yours
today by calling 877-709-7899
who heals all your diseases God can heal
all kinds of diseases and so we can just
thank him for that promise you know if
you look online if you just type in
Bible promises on healing there'll be a
whole list of them there verses you'll
see that you can claim those promises
now you know there are examples and I
just want to be balanced in my answer
there are examples in the Bible where
you have some people that got sick and
they prayed and God said no my strength
is made perfect in weakness this is what
God told the Apostle Paul but I do
believe that God can also miraculously
heal and we've heard that before I hope
that helps Tom you still there yeah I
agree
I've make you several times in late
during Alaska and I want you to remember
me every morning when you pray and get
your people to remember me to please
what Tom how about I pray for you right
now would that be okay yes that's the
best thing is to do it while we're
thinking about it let me just pray and
others listening can pray for Tom he
just got a serious diagnosis about
cancer just wherever you're driving down
the road father in heaven we just want
to join together as your people and
Tom's received a troubling report we
pray that you will work a miracle and
bring about his complete healing and
even through this whole trial I pray
that you can do in him what you need to
do and you can do through him what you
need to do as a witness for you and just
work it together for good Lord we thank
you and we pray this in Jesus name Amen
amen my loans are too bad to do surgery
oh okay well God's gonna work that out
we'll just continue to pray for you Tom
yeah I only use 14 percent lung capacity
and I'm 52 years old and I don't want to
I'm ready to go I'm not worried about
dying on you only all no it's sleep and
I'm ready to go but I want to stay
around and see my friend pastor Doug
it's you too let's go again
oh well bless your heart hey we'll keep
you in our prayers Tom and we thank you
for calling and and you
a lot of others I'm sure they're praying
for you as well thank you and we're
gonna talk next to Solomon calling from
Chicago Illinois Solomon you're on the
air uh hi pastor we got about two
minutes before we're gonna go to another
announcement okay so my question is from
2nd Kings chapter 2 verse 10 it's when
Elijah and Elisha are talking and Elisha
is about to go to heaven and Elisha
asked for a double portion of Elijah's
spirit and Elisha says this is a hard
thing seeing that most things are not
impossible with God I've always wondered
what Elisha meant when he said this was
a hard thing well the word hard there he
means you've asked me for a big thing
because giving the Holy Spirit is
something that God does a man doesn't do
it and so Elijah is saying to Elisha he
said you've asked the big thing but then
he goes on and says nevertheless even
though you've asked a big thing if you
see me when I'm taken from you if you
see it when I'm caught up
it'll be so if not it'll not be so and
the key there is he said you've got to
keep your eyes on me if you want to
receive the Holy Spirit that is really
reminding us that Jesus went to heaven
he told the Apostles I'm going to the
Father and if I go I will send the
comforter the Holy Spirit the Bible says
if he is lifted up we look at him he's
lifted up we fix our eyes on Jesus we
behold the lamb of God and as we look at
him we then receive the baptism of the
Holy Spirit and I really think that's
what that message is all about solomon
is now as we walk with jesus we keep our
eyes fixed upon christ as it says in
hebrews chapter 12 that if we see him
lift it up if we know he's in heaven
interceding for us we have nothing to
worry about we can receive that gift of
the holy spirit jesus said these things
I've done greater things than this will
you do and Elijah got a double portion
of Elijah's spirit it did happen you
know there's no prayer in the Bible God
did not answer there's never a prayer
where God said that's too hard I can't
do it
he even answered Joshua's prayer to make
the Sun stand still friends I can't make
the clock stand still and it looks like
we're gonna be out of time for tonight
we do have a couple of important
announcements following love to hear
from you go to amazing facts dot o RG
help keep us on the air god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic meltdown these are the images
people generally associate with the
tribulation and the day of the Lord but
did you know the Bible speaks about
another day of the Lord just before the
great Judgment Day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the Sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being a day the entire world
is largely forgotten you'll be surprised
to learn how this special day of the
Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit
AF bookstore com
what if you could know the future what
would you do what would you change to
see the future you must understand the
past Alexander the Great becomes king
when he's only 18 but he's a military
prodigy a hundred and fifty years in
advance Cyrus had been named Rahm was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined the Gospel writers see his
death as a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
Doug Batchelor explores the most
striking bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time get your copy
today available now on DVD blu-ray or
USB for more information visit kingdoms
in time.com
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world we've built churches in India
proclaim God's Word in China and have
sent free Bible studies around the globe
today's program and free resources were
made possible by our ministry partners
caring individuals like you if you've
been blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at